it is the 23rd of July today my name is
Jess McDowell and it's the time of the
day where I bring you a bunch of news so
let's get you all covered off there is a
new system update out for the ps4 and it
focuses on system stability if that
sounds somewhat familiar it's because
that was also the focus of the last two
updates 1.71 and 1.7 to update 1.7 for
yes you heard that right and no we don't
know what happened to 1.7 3 is indeed
going to attack the prevalent problem of
what sony has called system software
stability during use of some features
since the ps4 apparently has similar
stability issues to a hippo on roller
skates Sonia opting to continue to
refine that one presently it seems it'll
still be a while until we get new
features like those that came with the
1.7 update which came out in April
nonetheless Sony is pretty adamant about
the fact that they're more than happy to
gather your ideas for new features and
if you have no original ideas you can
head to the PlayStation Blog share
website and wrote up those belonging to
other people next up the destiny beta
has now gone live on xbox one and xbox
360 the beta was briefly offline for
maintenance but its back up earlier than
expected which is good news for xbox
owners who've been patiently waiting for
their turn to crack into the shooter if
you find yourself waiting on a code
Bungie are distributing them by email
gamers who log time in the game after 2
p.m. PT on July 26 welson agar
themselves an exclusive emblem for use
in the final game when it launches we
got some Microsoft numbers today in
terms of xbox one and xbox 360 sales and
here's what you need to know the company
has said that they've sold 1.1 million
xbox one and xbox 360 consoles between
April one and June 30 this year now to
sold in number though referencing the
number of consoles shipped to retailers
and not sold through to customers as has
been the case with most of Microsoft's
figures in the three months prior to
April Microsoft had shipped two million
consoles 1.2 million of which were Xbox
one's so it's a marked drop from earlier
this year the rest of the earnings
report can
be summed up in two microsoft is making
a whole bunch of money CEO satya nadella
also commented on the closure of xbox
entertainment studios saying that they
have decided to focus specifically on
gaming and that subsequently their
investment will be in core console
gaming and Xbox Live ask you a question
of the day let me know if you've had a
chance to crack into the Destiny Vader
and what you think of it if you like
conventions and livestream goodness and
it's well worth you knowing that san
diego comic-con is a thing that's
happening this week we will be having a
to our lab shirt from Thursday through
to saturday starting at 4pm PT each day
so visit gamespot to get stuck into that
for all the info and whatnot those are
all the good things i wanted to tell you
about today but tomorrow I'll be back
same time and place with more new so be
sure to join me then